yves
tu dois partir trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial
qu'est-ce que tu choisis muriel robin
catherine lara ou marie paule belle et
jeune homme sur un contre en ce moment
si tu avais pas le choix tu préférais
faire l'amour avec un mec très laid ou
une fille très belle c'est un mec très
mais parce que comme on dit royaume il y
en a qui ont des talents cachés un non
bâti avec une fille faut du matériel
s'est tout de suite ça entraîne des
frais a qui trouvent tue le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui tapent des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles de
circonstances atténuantes
oui à une bien qu'ils se tapent des
titres oui ça au moins on est sûr
qu'elle les a pas forcé au maire mes
bijoux une amie débarque chez toine a
prouvé qu est ce qui te gêne le plus
qu'elle trouve sur la table de nuit
mein kampf un godemichet à toute façon
c'est pas le même usage
mais j'ai lu avec intérêt certain
discours de hitler et effectivement
c'est assez impressionnant et non je
veux dire il peut m'arriver de lire ce
genre de truc c'est instructif
le mot le plus con en amour merci encore
oui oui le moule bio à je vous la
raconter notre propos c'est un camarade
à moi qui étais un peu fauchés et ebay
sa dulcinée un soir de noël et aux
grands moments que tu as ferrat et lady
joyeux noël
quand on n'a pas de thème c'est une
solution si c'était possible
est-ce que tu accepterais de décharger
une paralysie générale contre la faim
des inondations au bangladesh
ban
c'est à dire oui la charité chrétienne
me commanderait de choisir le bangladesh
mais je ne souhaite pas répondre là si
tu avais un perroquet tu lui apprendrait
d'affirmer le gaz tu as pensé la capote
ou alors coco arrête là coco a proposé
par ok faut que ça vachement petit tas
pour réussir à ton avis cette [ __ ]
calculatrice ou tueuse oh ça me déprime
ça ils sont un peu de naïveté là c'est
mon dernier reste